one
good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday Happy New
Year hope everybody had a fabulous
weekend speaking of fabulous here I am
here she is laughter you guys you're
probably shocked that turd ex flamingos
ex-flar to Studio X Jax X original
recipe is happening today I was supposed
to be home today but in a not so
shocking turn of events even though it
was shocking given the circumstances but
this happens every time you're here so
I'm sure the toasters aren't surprised
no but turdy extended her stay I did but
of course I had to do something like the
most dramatic way right I'm packing up I
leave I get in the Uber Harry's
literally in the driveway waving to his
auntie KOJA KOJA
what do I do in the car I cry and then
what do I do I call Ben and I say Ben I
don't think I can do it Ben says what if
I come down literally I'm like halfway
to the airport I'm like I'm so sorry sir
I forgot something we have to turn
around and then I like came back and I
didn't tell anyone and I was like so
dramatic I like walked through the door
with my bags it's literally like what's
that what's that movie it's from friends
like I got off the plane that was
literally me and like honestly everybody
was like like I I didn't feel like I was
being dramatic because everybody was
like she's here wait what are you doing
what's wrong like everybody was feeding
into like my dramatic fantasy and it
made the whole thing worth it it was a
very exciting thing I woke up to it
because I fell back asleep after the
early am feeding and I was looking
through the family chat Claudia had left
she sent a picture of herself in the
Uber crying and then I'm nursing on my
bed I still haven't gotten up yet like
for the day and I hear Claudia's voice
like coming down my hallway I'm like
Claudia but I I figured actually it's
probably Olivia sounding like Claudia or
maybe like somebody's playing a video of
mine maybe and then she walked in the
door I was like what no like one thing
about me like my life is moving like my
life is a film are you saying you're
giving main character energy no I
wouldn't say that I'm giving main
character energy one because only losers
say that and to be honest no main
character has like really actually ever
said that like not to be a [__]
um and two I'm not giving mink like I am
you know the main character you can give
something that you already are if that
makes sense but I feel like I'm the main
character why would you I mean you
definitely like the main character of
your life I feel like it's one of those
movies like you know there's two main
characters like Valentine's Day or Love
Actually where there's a lot of main
characters I disagree I disagree I think
it's like the type of movie with too
many like it's it's Romy and Michelle
yeah like they're both like honestly I
couldn't even really say who's better
Romy or Michelle no it's not about who's
better it's about who's the main
character they're really 50 50. but it
just begs the question like who did you
like better Romy or Michelle
like she was living in a fantasy and
like she was they both were no but like
Romy at least like had a grip on reality
I felt like Romy was like always kind of
shielding Michelle from like the real
story but Romy was the reason that he
got himself into such trouble because
Romy cared so much what other people
thought whereas Michelle was just going
with the phone she wasn't ashamed of
their life you know and she would have
been happy to show up at the reunion
yeah as who she was was Romy who wanted
bigger and better for them who wanted
there's more than her station you're so
right
you're so right so so I guess there was
one who was better Michelle yeah well
you thought it was rummy so I didn't say
I thought it was very I'm saying
arguments could be made for both yeah
even though obviously like ushered them
through life but she took a lot of Wrong
Turns it's true but you know it's at
least they got somewhere yes sir it's
true I don't know if they would get
anywhere I don't know if they would have
had a roof over their heads had it not
been for Romy right okay I'm glad we got
to the bottom of that both are important
so it was a fabulous weekend we
celebrated the Jewish New Year happy
Russia shout out to everyone and what's
even more fabulous about it is since we
were all together for the holiday we
vlogged not once but twice part two will
be going up today correct part two is
going up today so part one went up on
Saturday it was Olivia's night of Rosh
Hashanah she hosted night one and
Claudia and Marco took us behind the
scenes of her kitchen which I loved
watching because I didn't get to see her
cooking process
I wish I watched it before I made my
night because then I could see how she
did her birthday because you kept
telling me what she was doing yeah but
she did night one the Vlog is so amazing
so many scenes I pop in for a second but
I'm I'm not the main character
definitely not I'm like not even
supporting I'm an extra you're a
background actor for sure giving extra
no you're like man in taxi you know
because you had a lie I know I'm a woman
with Baby by the way you're literally
breastfeeding Mama a woman with baby in
Vlog number one but in Vlog number two
the witch drops today I'm the star I'm
the main character energy and I'm kind
of like Remy the Ratatouille the rat of
all my dreams I'm kind of like the rat
in your ear in the kitchen yeah you are
the supporting Remy actor I would say
if they're giving Oscars for logs like I
would be nominated for
best actress but I would also be
nominated in like director category and
perhaps like stage design yeah and maybe
like writer girl writer girl yeah okay
that's fair
um so then part two for everyone there
is room for everyone so I won't spoil it
but night two like we were coming off of
Olivia's amazing hosting of night one
honestly when we got home from her
dinner we were like why did we even
bother yeah um and we were following
this kind of I would say Advanced recipe
for a brisket for a brisket from Jake
Owen's new cookbook and I won't lie like
we were cursing Jake Owen's name in our
sleep well I don't want to spoil but
well yeah anything the Vlog is one hour
of clubs one hour of Claudia and I
cooking a six pound brisket and it is
it's cinematic gold and it's dropping
today so that's at patreon.com the toast
not only are we cooking a six pound
brisket but we are in foul moods like
really foul Jackie was obviously just
like over tired from being a mother
usually trying to be positive when we're
feeling sour we're cooking the brisket
at midnight yeah it was
it was one of the worst experiences of
my life but it was all worth it because
we got a vlog out of it right so we got
a brisket For Better or For Worse you'll
have to you'll have to you'll have to
find out how the brisket turned out but
that'll be fun and that was going up
today so it was an eventful weekend
really eventful so much fun in the sun
so much fun in the sun so much time with
the kids so many core memories I'm just
like Tick-Tock jargon girl today yeah
you're like delayed like all these
things like popped off like a year ago
but no but they're still part of the
vernacular kind of it was core memory
building season over here at at the
Australia wine red Shapiro's offer
household
um
and it was sad obviously because like
Ben wasn't here he spent Rosh Hashanah
with his family but he got here last
night
and I'm just ready to do it all over
again like making new core memories with
Uncle Ben so you're saying you want to
start all over you know I don't know if
you listen to Ben's most recent episode
on the toast but he was saying he's like
in love with Olivia Rodrigo he like
loves her music it's so bad it's like
Rockery and he's been listening to her
album so much and he gets in bed last
night and I was reading and listening to
music and Olivia Rodrigo's album was on
and Ben like he thought he was about to
make the most sick call ever he's like
he points to the screen he's like this
song
you're gonna freak out it sounds just
like start all over I'm Miley Cyrus I'm
like we know like everyone's talking
about it we know yeah she's gonna have
to give another writing credit yeah yeah
and I'm like no no we know thanks for
joining us like he thought he had a fire
point and then shut him down that's good
that's to destroy a man's confidence
before noon that's really good for your
marriage yeah and speaking of my
marriage we celebrated our six year
anniversary yesterday which was why Ben
flew down I was going to come home early
and he was like let me just it was like
a whole thing whatever
um and I got him a gift did you see my
gift I did I got him a cameo Cameo is
honestly sometimes like the best gift we
I told him I'm like no there's a time
and a place I don't want like I think
between like Hanukkah birthdays
anniversaries Valentine's Day like what
I'm supposed to drop so much money and
been supposed to drop so much money on
me I honestly find gift giving to be
incredibly wasteful so we haven't been
like in our gift giving era sustainable
30 well yeah I am turning 30 next year
and I do like want something big so just
make sure he takes care of that for sure
do you have any ideas in mind because
he's always asking but I can't have a
trip honestly oh you wouldn't experience
maybe okay so um
we don't really do gifts anymore I
honestly I just find it such a waste of
money but this year I got a macamia
which is like a gag gift even though it
was like kind of pricey was it yeah I
mean he must have upped his price I got
him a a cameo from Rick Hoffman who we
all know as Lewis lit from Suits and we
also know him as an upcoming character
in the Thanksgiving movie that his price
went up because suits is number one on
Netflix right now right so I think all
in all it's like a little under 300
between like taxes Apple fees all that
stuff
um he delivered it in a couple of days
it was three minutes long it was so
thoughtful and funny and honestly it
made Ben laugh so much if you're like in
your suits ERA with your husband right
now like get him a gift like Ben was
dying there was something like
inherently you and I were talking about
this I think privately uncomfortable
about receiving a cameo I find it really
hard to receive cameos and you've gotten
me I've gotten a few cameos over the
years from all different kinds of
celebrities and I haven't found like a
cameo that I enjoy receiving I got her
one from mantitea when she became
obsessed with that documentary yeah
which was so like cute and toppable like
I just like died listening to it I can't
explain it I've you got me one from
Carlin Carlin from The Real Housewives
of Salt Lake City's daughter my best one
that I've received but I have like a
really hard time receiving cameos and
then one time like Damon John made me
one yep and Bethany made you one and
hi it has nothing to do with Damon but
like you physically
physically recoiled hearing Damon like
recite whatever like he was things about
you it was about me I just seriously
wanted to die by the way I didn't use it
as a story today but are you following
this Bethany saga no okay you know she's
like makeup girly Tick Tock like
whatever she like part of her
personality on Tick Tock is that she's
so rich but she shops at TJ Maxx and
like I don't know I guess we're supposed
to clap and
um the one in I think in the Hamptons
that she goes to she like knows the
staff there because she's there all the
time and she brought them like this big
bag of makeup that you know she gets so
much PR and she brought them this big
bag of makeup and the ladies were like
oh thank you like we're not allowed to
except she's like don't worry I'll email
corporate like take this and she got the
whole thing on video and it was just
like I think her heart was in the right
place but it was deeply painful and
uncomfortable to watch and she's being
dragged for it like Beyond a lot of
people said a lot that some of the
makeup was used and like why would you
go do that and then like to assert your
power and be like I will email your
manager like it was giving Karen energy
a little bit of positive care I'm just
trying to do good but it's like that's
the thing I watched the video and like
you said physically recoiled in my seat
but I don't think you know her heart was
in the wrong place yeah but I I just I
can't get I can't personally get behind
doing acts of good deeds and filming
them yeah don't do it no don't like
you're not helping I I like that's a
whole but then there's this other side
of tick tock where people
um there are a lot of videos of people
doing good deeds and they're amazing to
watch yeah and you know that like
because they film them they get money
from it and then they like do this thing
where it's like when a lot of people I
follow they do this thing where when
they make a thousand dollars in The Tick
Tock Creator fund they'll give that as
one big tip so like a server or somebody
working at you know like a barista and
so you need the videos in order to do
the acts of Good Deeds
um but something like that with Bethany
like honestly like just don't like
that's the lesson I think here for
Bethany yeah so I guess we can't make
any blanket statements like don't do
good in video right it's a case case
situation it is but just use your
judgment like most things like most
things but I didn't choose that as a
story
um good I don't know why like Bethany
Making Waves in her videos and stuff
like just doesn't do it for me positive
or negative yeah no I feel that she's
definitely like a weird wave of her
career yeah where she's kind of becoming
like tabloid fodder yeah but she seems
to be enjoying herself yeah and the more
like I don't think any amount of
backlash is going to stop her from doing
what she's doing she kind of like lives
for it she does and she's also she's
like uncancelable like she's a very
successful person her now like second
wind as a creator of some sorts is
definitely making her money but it's
borderline like a hobby so it's not like
you could all stop watching her videos
and she'll not have you know money to
put on the table like right she's in a
weird position where she really is like
not cancelable but I guess that also
makes whatever she's doing very
authentic to her because she's not
saying anything to appease anyone that's
true that's always interesting it is
if you're interested so it's like a
little a little a moose boosh you know
not a story but a little moose oh a
little teaser story I don't know what
the stories are we're doing a swap today
because I was running so late this
morning so Claudia picked the stories
and actually some of the ads that we
have today that he's really passionate
about and they asked for me they did
let's talk about that like ongoing Trend
in our business where certain brands are
reaching out asking for Jackie to read
the ads it's hurtful like have I not
done a good job these last six years but
it makes sense because they're brands
that really only I am using yeah of
course I mean Dreamland baby swaddle of
course right and we have two today one
of them like yeah they definitely they
definitely chose you found favor because
they know how passionate I am about the
brand and you know what that's okay and
sometimes I don't get to exercise my
passions about the ads because like we
hit the timer and it's time to move on
yeah so today I get to share everything
and there are a couple brands in here
I'm really passionate about I'm not
going to say which ones because I don't
know which ones right
um also I am unfortunately going to have
to leave your house at some point
because my book club meets this week and
I'm about halfway through the book I
don't know if I updated everyone on the
book that I chose you didn't but are you
going to read somewhere is that what
you're saying you're gonna have to leave
my house no I have to leave because book
club is meeting and I have to make the
meeting
I never thought a book club could be a
negative thing I know I know I never
thought I would you know find this favor
with your book club so if you followed
me on Instagram I had four books Jackie
had recommended codename Helene I wanted
to do I think I pretty much landed on
historical fiction so I got a bunch of
wrecks I whittled it down to four and I
posted on my Instagram to have everyone
vote for which would be the one that
that I chose and for some reason I ended
up choosing the one with the least
amount of Oats
why I don't know I just read the
description and I was like compelled by
it and you followed your heart I
followed my heart and you know I'm on
this like kind of like history Journey
where I like low-key know nothing about
history it's actually embarrassing and
when I've been reading a lot of World
War II books I've kind of been focusing
on different countries like when I read
the rose code I learned all about
England during World War II when I read
the Nightingale I learned all about
France and then one of the books that I
thought about reading was Italy and I
was like what was going down in italic I
had no idea I knew England when I read
the rose code I knew England was like a
main character of World War II then when
I read the Nightingale I'm like what the
hell did go down in France turned out
they just like rolled over and let the
Nazis come in then I'm like what
happened with Italy so you know what I
was like I feel like this is a good
journey for me yeah it's 600 pages
though which is a lot I'm 50 through
it's an incredibly compelling story
I will say I do think the book requires
the basic background like minimal
knowledge on like the main characters in
Italy during the war the war do you have
those no but let me tell you what I do
have a Kindle and I was talking to my
friend from book club last night he's
like oh I decided to read it hardcover
I'm like you know what I think that was
a mistake because do you know how many
things I have highlighted and read the
Wikipedia on just because the author
does not do a good job of like giving
background people or both terms terms
like a lorry what the just say truck
there were so many lorries Lori this
Lori that German lorries German
laureates and after about the tenth time
I'm like I thought I would read it and
then they would explain it like I would
figure it out context clues what the
[__] is a lorry it's a truck okay so so
it's not beginner it's not beginner and
it's a true story about this guy named
Pinole and it's an incredibly compelling
story like I don't know what ended up
happening to happening to him but he had
this amazing story like it's like one of
the untold journeys of the war and I
just feel like the writer is doing
everything he can to like make it not
compelling he's it's he's saying not
doing the story justice but the story is
so good that the book is still good but
had I realized at the time that the book
was written by a man
I wouldn't have chosen it like I'm gonna
say something crazy right now
writing is for girls like
men are not good writers I literally
have only read a handful of books by men
and they stink and they get like special
treatment in the men the silent patient
everyone's like the best book like it
was you know covered wall to wall every
bookstore every Goodreads stunk it up
stunk it up like the bar is low for the
man I'm not reading books my man anymore
it's not for them I respect your opinion
I think writing is for everyone and I
disagree because I feel like the books
I've read by men are so good
because all of the books I read Are by
women so there's going to be a lot more
variation but when something by a man
like comes across my desk like it
usually is good because all of the books
I see are like the women are
platformed more I like I like I think
men like genuinely can't write and then
it makes me question like the great
writers you know Shakespeare do you
think it was bad I think like if there
had been equal opportunity in writing
for women during you know Hemingway's
time during William Shakespeare's time
like and I think if we had put the best
female writer up against Shakespeare
like honestly I think Shakespeare
wouldn't have said a chance like this is
just a theory I have because men can't
write like they're literally not good at
it it's funny it's just a thought let me
know in your comment and like in the
comments do you think men can write well
for certain genres I I would prefer a
woman oh my God I would never read like
a romance novel by a man like literally
who cares I know but like these women
are so delusional that's what makes it
good it's a fantasy Jackie I know but
it's like I think we're leading people
down an unrealistic paths and I think
like everyone's just like sitting around
waiting so you mean that boss of yours
who's a billionaire it's not gonna come
into my tiny square like 10 foot square
10 square foot apartment and offer me to
be the president because he sees
something in me the president and his
wife but of course the president and in
turn his wife yeah you don't think
that's gonna happen I think we're
setting unrealistic standards for young
women no that's the thing what's so
great about romance novels like it's
really like it's so unrealistic that
it's it's fantasy yeah honestly some of
them I think some people Jackie
some of the romance books I read like
really should be categorized under
fantasy some people haven't gotten that
memo though yet so like they're sitting
around waiting for their Christian Gray
to walk through the door totally
separate like tangent where you look
gorgeous like really stunning and
Jackie's wearing her hair oh naturality
today because she came out into the
kitchen she's like I have to do my hair
I'm like no you don't it looks gorgina
I'm letting this half up half down fresh
face all white like it's giving
what is it giving hold on
I want to find the perfect word okay
it's giving
what is the word I'm looking for maybe
I'm not the good writer it's
well first of all it's giving luxury the
whole look oh my God thank you but but
your face it's giving unbridled
peace if that makes sense maybe that's
because my wonderful turdy lose stayed a
few more days maybe I'm feeling at peace
and we had a great weekend but thank you
yes I'm wearing my hair natural because
Claudia was like no it looks so good it
really does and I didn't know if it was
because she wanted to get the show on
the road because we're running a little
late today because I was running a
little late today but you know what it
is what it is let's give her a shot my
natural hair I can't recall the last
time I wore it natural on the show I do
want to be completely honest like part
of me telling you to wear your natural
hair was like I want to get my day
started like let's get the show on the
road but I never would have let you like
walk out with ugly hair your hair
actually looked beautiful so it helped
my case that you not doing your hair
moved things along got it it's just
being honest if I'm gonna be honest I
appreciate your honesty oh wouldn't you
talk about also another major major like
life-altering update from this weekend
two things okay we stayed number one on
the podcast charts the entire weekend
everybody loved our Friday episode
Friday's episode hit number one as well
because the other episode of ours that
hit number one Wednesday it was Audio
Only which means that we had a couple
extra movers and shakers propping us to
the top but then Friday we're back on
YouTube so we split the audience again
right which we're happy to do we're
happy to take the hit
but our courage was rewarded because we
were number one and Not only was it
rewarded it was rewarded double time
because it turns out a little birdie
named Aaron Rodgers saw our Instagram
post about about content we should
suggest to him to listen to while he
heals and he liked our rendition of the
sun is rising by Britt Nicole he liked
it he liked the real he liked it
physically and animation emotionally too
because I don't think he would like it
physically if he didn't like it
emotionally because he seems like the
kind of guy who means what he says and
it just begs the question like is Aaron
Rodgers in love with us
sorry Aaron we're taken I don't know my
wedding ring hasn't been fitting
recently same for different reasons
physically it hasn't been fitting but
emotionally not really either because
I've been so transfixed on like my
relationship with Aaron Rodgers hmm
he's single I know last I heard last I
heard on the toast
um okay
one other thing to say one other thing
because as fall turns and the leaves
change we are getting closer and closer
to my book being released oh my God and
not us being like women who don't
support female authors we have nuts it's
disgusting we haven't spoken about my
book in a little while I've had a lot
going on a ton but now it's time to rev
it up yep prepare to be sick of me
prepare to be sick of me because my
debut book which is a children's book is
coming out on October 10th it's called
the camper and the counselor and I'm so
so so excited I still read it every
single day and night to Harry he loves
it beyond words and I'm so excited for
all of you to get your hands on it and
here's why you should get it for a
multitude of reasons what if you like
this show like support your girl in her
debut of course but if you have a child
in your life whether it be a daughter a
son a niece a nephew a cousin whatever
you know some child grandchild someone
who feels like family but you don't even
you're not a child dog child
um you want to give them this book
because like it's actual joy in a book
first of all it Rhymes and you know as a
very involved Auntie I'm seeing the
trend in children's literature is moving
away from rhyming and I think that's the
wrong choice and I think it's wrong for
the kids I think it's a you know
neglectful in my opinion and Jackie
wasn't going to let that happen she said
this book is going to rhyme whether you
[__] like it or not and not only does
it rhyme it bounces like you could just
be reading that book you could read that
book and your shoulder you won't even
notice your shoulders just like the one
to Kim Brooks gives me goosebumps and
chills right here I yell as we pull into
the drive we've made it to Camp I'm so
glad to arrive like it has melodic
qualities it has Rhythm it has the beat
it'll bring joy to your kids and if you
like love a child in your life like why
would you want to make them unhappy give
them the book give them the book you can
search it on Amazon I'm available
everywhere Barnes Noble Indie bound go
to the camper and the counselor.com
will direct you to where you could get
it you could still get a kind signed
copy via Talk Shop live you can so
that's really exciting October 10th
prepare to be sick of me and I hope that
you get the book and that you're gonna
love the book that'll be so exciting
when that comes out and we get like so
many pictures and videos on Instagram of
like kids loving the book no and I'm so
excited because right now I've only
teased the first few pages so people
don't like know the plot the plot I
really don't want to give too much away
but I'm just really excited for when
people finish the book it has twists and
turns it does highs and lows it's not
what you expect but it's not too scary I
don't know there's just like it's for
children of all ages yeah I would say
zero to eight because
um I've been reading it to Harry since
since he was born because that was when
I wrote the first draft when I was nine
months pregnant and as he gets older he
loves it more more but it's also great
for kids who are going to camp for the
first time and might be feeling a little
trepidatious homesick and that's at
eight years old I don't want to spoil it
but like camper does you know experience
a bout of homesickness she goes through
some [__] yeah no she's kind of like a
little all over the place but that's why
we love her yeah she's happy she's sad
it's like get together girl and that's
why she needs counseling
enter counselor snitch counselor and you
don't need to be familiar with this
podcast too if you like understand the
book understood why I call Margo
counselor or counselor snitch it doesn't
it's irrelevant to the story it's just
counselor snitches in the book and
thankfully she was inspired by Margo
yeah so it'll be fabulous but she's a
bit of everyone in her she better yeah
she better
so I'm excited about that check it out
me too and now without further Ado no I
feel as though we can get into the fast
five stories that you need to know
but again I spoke too soon because there
are some things I need to let you know
spoke too soon which is that today's
episode is brought to you by Braun Braun
is a trusted 100 year old brand with
quality products that are built to last
the brown ear thermometers are
clinically proven as accurate as rectal
so parents don't have to compromise
their comfort or baby's comfort for the
sake of accuracy okay I am obsessed with
Braun I use my Braun thermometer I told
you guys Harry was sick last week and up
until a month or two ago we were using
rectal thermometers and it was really
disruptive like you have a sick kid all
of a sudden you say no but when you have
a baby it's okay but now with kids like
they don't want you know pan sound
diaper off it's very disruptive so I had
just gotten my Brawn ear thermometer
because they sent us um product a few
months ago and it was literally in his
room and ready and the ear thermometer
was so amazing and so accurate and not
only do they give a thermometer but it
also comes with an app where you can
clock what their temperature is at what
times when they got medicine we can
never run membership what time did you
give him the medicine so Braun has
everything because a fever in newborns
can be more concerning so the fever
threshold is lower Braun has developed
age Precision technology to take the
guesswork out the Braun thermoscan 7
plus ear thermometer provides age-based
fever Guidance with a green yellow or
red reading so you scan the ear really
quickly and then the thermometer lights
up with it whether it's green or yellow
or red and we'll tell you what kind of
Zone you're in and if you need to be
worried this helps parents so they can
understand the severity of the fever
based on the child's age and they don't
need to spend time looking up all the
information also the thermometer is
connected will sync up to the Braun
Family Care app the app is a place where
you can track temperature readings log
symptoms and medications and set
reminders for medicine and doctor's
appointments this app is a game changer
for those Middle of the Night Fever
episodes when you can't remember the
last time you gave a kid medicine and
now another child is sick now you can
keep everything together in one place
for the whole family plus if one of you
has to go to the doctor with the kid and
the doctor starts asking what what was
his temperature when to give him
medicine you don't have to remember all
of it it's just in the especially if
both parents or caretakers can't make it
so visit Amazon search for the bronze
smart thermometer and use code 20 toast
at checkout for 20 off your order
so that's at Amazon Brawn smart
thermometer use code 20 toast at
checkout for 20 off of your order you
guys this thermometer was so so helpful
next up today's episode is brought to
you by Babel another sponsored fashion
oozing through me this fall you can
start speaking a new language with Babel
why Babble Claudia because it's the best
because it works instead of paying
hundreds of dollars for a private tutor
or fooling yourself with language apps
that are a little more than games
Babel's quick 10 minute lessons are
designed by over 150 language experts to
help you start speaking a new language
in as little as three weeks
apple is designed for real people for
real conversations all of Babel's tips
and tools for learning a new language
are approachable accessible rooted in
real life situations and delivered with
conversation-based teachings so if
you're going on a trip or you just want
to expand your mind learning a new
language is a great way your man the
rest will follow that it's a great way
to exercise your brain muscles you know
it's one of the most difficult things to
do with Babel they make it so easy
digestible snackable it's also just like
much safer if you're traveling to a
country to have like a basic grasp of
the knowledge yeah basic knowledge
basic grasp on The Language basic
knowledge I need Babel for English like
um it's just safer and it's a more
efficient way of traveling yes so if you
want to learn a new language by
Thanksgiving wow yeah where are we
taking a trip Espana
where are we going I don't know we can
go anywhere anywhere with Babel here's a
special limited time deal for our
listeners to get you started right now
get 55 off your Babel subscription but
only for our listeners at babel.com
toast that's 55 off at babel.com toast
spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com toast rules and
restrictions May apply now I just want
to say you know I love Babel because of
the way that it's the name of it is you
know yeah Tower of Babel Tower of Babel
which is reminding me of this Tick Tock
Trend that I want to talk about oh sure
the Roman Empire yeah which everyone is
asking their husbands how often they
think about the Roman Empire because
apparently men think about the Roman
Empire almost every day it's like a
theory on Tick Tock that like grown men
are constantly thinking of the Roman
Empire and people are filming themselves
asking their husbands and boyfriends and
they're being like honestly like a
couple times a week yeah and I was not
convinced that Ben would
feel the same and I did it last night he
was like I didn't even know what the
Roman Empire was like famously I didn't
know what the [__] it was either I knew
for a fact that my husband wasn't
thinking about the Roman Empire yeah
once a week Nothing in life is
guaranteed but I knew for a fact but I
knew for a fact but that's how I feel
about the Tower of Babel you fight so
now the question has been posed on Tick
Tock what is the female equivalent of
the Roman Empire like what historical
tragedies or Mysteries do plague women
that and some of the answers are Helen
Keller
the Titanic that's what I was gonna say
um Chernobyl
Chernobyl but I feel like people didn't
know a lot about Chernobyl until that
show came out yeah how are you really
thinking about it no I think the Titanic
is like the perfect answer yeah I was I
said the Titanic we were talking about
at dinner the Tower of Babel for me for
you the Holocaust
I was gonna say the Holocaust but I
think that's exclusive to like Jewish
women let us know yeah if you're not a
Jews how often do you think about the
Holocaust probably every day definitely
but I definitely think about the
Holocaust every day I probably think
about the Tower of Babel once a week
I've actually never thought of it in my
life like that's so crazy yeah
that's crazy
but like just if your man isn't thinking
about the Roman Empire like it's okay I
just I didn't see anyone else posting
like that their husbands had no idea
what that was like let me ask you a
question
what's the Roman Empire like when
oh it's in Rome it's in Rome and it was
like the greatest civilization
up until that point and I guess since
then
um but then it collapsed but after like
hundreds how did it collapse you know
got too big for its britches well that's
so us right now like that's what's gonna
happen to us yeah totally yeah um okay a
lot of it like advances and technology
technology technology like medicine
mathematics architecture a lot of it
comes from Rome so I think like when
people see uh you know arches or
highways that's when men are like always
thinking about the Roman Empire
interesting highways not highways but
like I don't know because Shapiro said
when he's on the highway or something he
thinks oh Shapiro thinks about the Roman
Empire there was like a thing that makes
him think or some one of the videos I
saw because there are things in everyday
life that like came from the Roman
Empire so that's when these men went in
this room came from the Roman Empire
why don't you search Roman Empire
inventions
it's also like Concepts you know
inventions Roman Empire okay here
10 inventions to thank the Roman Empire
for from graylinerome.com cement okay
right so he's on the highway the
aqueduct they didn't invent the idea of
transporting water they were primitive
canals and other water transportation
systems in place before ancient Roman
times but they harnessed the idea
developed and refined it using their
engineering skills to build the aqua so
that's like Plumbing no well sanitation
that's in a Roman Empire thing that they
gave us they brought clean water into
cities and towns and they kept waste
away from Clear clean water they also
developed sewers to take waste out of
the Cities oh wow they use I'm gonna
start thinking about the Roman Empire
they use the water from the aqueducts to
flush the sewers and the drains many of
the homes in the city were connected to
its sewage sewer sewer Ridge structure
so Plumbing oh roads
that's why Shapiro said Highway got it
social care and Welfare
ancient Roman administrations developed
welfare type programs they developed
laws that provided money to help feed
and educate orphans and poorer children
from society the Julian calendar which
is 365 days a year elements of surgery
well they were lit back in the day they
built uh on the developments that the
Greeks made in surgery they developed
many new surgical tools and techniques
they use an early form of antiseptic in
surgery and they acknowledge that you
need to clean and dip your surgical
tools before use they developed the idea
of the cesarean section
and they pioneered Battlefield surgery
and for them being prepared to medically
help their soldiers was a key part of
being battle ready modern elements of
the modern legal system are also from
the Romans uh the concept of being
innocent until proven guilty that's so
interesting
and newspapers and public press
the Postal Service
okay that's it that was ten that's for
sure there's more right so now you know
I guess men are always thinking about
those things oh of course Roman numerals
um the newspaper yeah
yeah all these are oh The Arches you're
right they invented arches
aqueducts okay all these things are
saying the same thing I just want to
make sure we miss anything concrete
roads
oh
like books but in the way that we know
them now like with covers and rounded
the shape yeah the shape of books like
books and bit were like before but
that's a lot and so when we talk we're
talking Romans we're talking about like
Julius Caesar right yeah amongst others
this is it gives such a dumb question
like I'll be like actually mortified if
you agree
Julius Caesar feels fictional yeah but
like those were real people Caesar yeah
it's not a book no but I think it was uh
um
I think it's like a sh
there's a fictional word they're not a
fictional but like somebody like there's
a book it's not Shakespeare I think it's
Shakespeare yeah the Ides of March our
cup yeah yeah okay search Julius Caesar
Shakespeare just to confirm
but that does make it feel fictional
well the iPad is listening to us like
literally first saying well I wrote
William Shakespeare Julius Caesar yeah
yeah he wrote a story about Caesar
because he was always thinking about the
Roman Empire because he was a man now
here's my question like we were in
school with all these boys who um were
obsessed with the Roman Empire and it's
like when did they learn all these
things about the Roman Empire that stuck
with them because like I was in the same
class and I have really not nobody very
at best like grasp yeah what I've shared
today is all like right right so like
what are they watching maybe there was
like no it sounded like they were like
secret meetings with boys to talk about
the Roman Empire or like were they all
jazzed in sixth grade about this social
studies lesson about the Roman Empire
like when did the obsession start and
where are they learning about it I don't
know in present day I don't know because
that's something I could get into you
know I like to fall down a historical
right I could go for the women Empire
but what are the best Roman shows
sound off in the comments sound off in
the comments where could we learn more
all right our first story a little bit
of an update Ashton Kutcher has resigned
as chairman of his anti-sex abuse
organization Thorne over the Danny
Masterson character statement so he's
stepping back from his leadership role
at Thorne which is an anti-human
Trafficking Organization which was
co-founded by Ashton the star and
producer resigned as board chair in a
letter to the board published to the
organization's website on Friday the
letter cited Kutcher and Mila Kunis's
character letter for convicted rapist
and fellow that 70 show star Danny
Masterson here's what he wrote after my
wife and I spent several days of
listening personal reflection learning
and conversations with survivors and the
employees in leadership at Thorne I have
determined the responsible thing for me
to do is resign as chairman of the board
effective immediately I cannot allow my
error and judgment to distract from our
efforts and the children we serve
victims of sexual abuse have been
historically silenced in the character
statement I submitted is yet another
painful instance of questioning victims
who are brave enough to share their
experiences this is precisely what we
have all worked to reverse over the last
decade the mission must always be the
prior party and I want to offer my
heartfelt apology to all victims of
sexual violence and everyone at Thorn
who I know who I hurt by what I did and
to the broader advocacy Community I am
deeply sorry
so this to me makes no sense like
actually yeah I think it makes sense and
it makes no sense because it's like okay
you harm the community now you're gonna
help them less no I I know I actually
think him stepping down from this
organization that he started like he
didn't have to step down it's his like
company
um he doesn't like this company actually
does like amazing life-saving work and
like he doesn't want his [__] to be
like for people now to doubt the
organization or for the or right the
organization's reputation to like who
would doubt the organization some haters
on Twitter
advocacy Community this is like a really
big Scandal like it's a big Scandal for
us of course but like but if the work is
the work the work is the work I agree
but I I actually can respect like
actions speak louder than words I can
respect him not wanting like his scandal
right now to affect this company that
he's built over the last 10 years like I
can actually I can understand that line
of thinking okay what I don't understand
is like so so he's not gonna work for it
anymore so he would but so the company
will will not have at like his whatever
he contributes money connections and
whatever like
no what I don't understand is like
so he's so they have completely reneged
on the letter like them writing the
letter was kind of this Brave choice
that they had to have thought it through
extensively before deciding to do it and
just in an instant
they like I don't I just that to me to
me so they didn't know there they worked
in advocacy for 10 years
they've built this organization and they
didn't know the harm in writing that
letter like they knew and it was a tough
position and they decided to do it but
now they're like oh I'm sorry I wish I
didn't do it let me like let me like
erase everything I've ever done and
change my whole life because right but
so
now you know the theory that me that
they were blackmailed into it's like the
only way I can really seriously like
understand the story
I I just don't understand them like as
people right now yeah like stand for
some like this is so I feel unnecessary
and crazy to me that they would really
like just continue to just
debase themselves like you okay like you
wrote the letter but this is your
company and you want to help victims of
sexual violence like so do the work and
help them don't do less work you know
that's actually a very fair way of
looking at it that's how I read it which
is like okay the whole time yes you
wrote the letter but we can always use
their advocacy work to show how much
they yeah and support victims so now
you're not going to support the victims
anymore so you really don't you're it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy I think
like a lot of people expected this I
think of it as like a PR move I think
it's a horrible piano music but I
thought the apology was a horrible PR
move I think everything that they're
doing is and I really can't believe that
there are people advising them and even
the two of them themselves that can't be
smart enough to see that they are
literally like ruining their reputations
by standing for absolutely nothing and
now they're taking away away from
themselves like the one good thing that
they were doing yeah no I completely and
it's like if he's stepping down in name
only and still going to work behind the
scenes and provide everything he's
providing to the organization then this
is just a lie a lie and
phone like so what would you have said
would have been the best they wrote the
letters and everybody found out right
what would you do a strong statement
about who they are what they do and why
they did what why they made the decision
that they made as best as they could
explain it to people who will never
understand I think they should have just
shut the [__] up like write the letter
that you you obviously I can't diminish
the position they were put in being
asked to write those letters by Danny's
Family and like his daughter I imagine
that was incredibly difficult like I can
respect that it was a hard decision and
they came to the conclusion that they
were going to write the letters
we would not be talking about it today
we would have talked about it last week
when it came out be like oh it's crazy
we would have been like oh what a crazy
time I wonder why they did it I wonder
we would have wondered but we wouldn't
know as much as we know now and I think
we would not still be talking about it
it would be something we moved on from
they would be pretty unmarred by it and
then like you know it would be one of
those things we always like be like how
crazy was that yeah that was a weird
thing they did but even they then
apologized yeah and they should have let
it end with that I don't know what's
going on behind the scenes for them
what's going on the advocacy world but
they're two people who don't really need
a lot of the
internal politics that other people like
they have the money they have the cloud
they have the friends and people who
will help them if not they don't even
need help they can do all of this work
with on their own on their own so I
don't know why they keep dragging it
down in it and just like they keep like
hitting themselves how it's against the
wall like badass and bad it's like
no you made a decision
well it was it the one I would have made
no but you made a decision stick with it
yeah like stand by what really what from
this this experience we've what have we
learned what do they stand for I don't
know now they don't even stand for
Thorns right that work that they do
how do they have one fan left they've
pissed off everyone everyone with every
opinion about what they did nobody is
watching this being like actually doing
the right thing no it's like it's very
poorly handled yeah which is so crazy
because you know they have the best of
the best crisis PR publicist I just I
don't know I feel like someone is
intentionally blowing up their careers
and I feel the same way about probably
what's our next story about the shows
that were coming back that are no longer
coming back where it's like why are
people would you like to go to the next
story go to the next story because it
feels like people are seriously like
deciding to blow up their careers yes
because they're just done because
they're for the board no so Drew
Barrymore has now decided to pause her
talk show following the backlash Amanda
strikes I'm not gonna read this article
here's what happened she said she was
bringing a show back she did it in like
a very weird wishy-washy like granola
statement that really didn't explain her
reasonings yeah
so there was backlash and I think it was
part and due to the fact that people
just didn't understand why she was doing
it had she given a good reason I.E Bill
Maher Bill Mars bringing a show back
people aren't rioting he wrote a
Facebook posts because his listeners are
quite old and he was like listen I
sympathize with the writers I'm on their
team but there are hundreds of other
people who work for my show who are not
protected by a union who are going broke
in solidarity with this Union and like
they need to work and so I'm bringing my
show back without writers I'm not going
to do my monologue because that's what
the writers are the show won't be as
good because I don't have writers but
you know what people will get the show
will go on it was so clear why you did
it what his reasonings were and you know
what I could understand it like actually
I agree she and so then she did another
video Drew after the backlash that was
even less clear she was crying it was uh
a mess and then she ended up deleting it
so all these big decisions being made
this is a million honestly a billion
dollar brand she has like with the TV
show the makeup she puts out this blurry
crying video and deletes it like I can't
get behind that and now she's not
bringing her show back
and I don't know what crisis PR person
in the world would like all this happen
would let all this happen so I have to
imagine she doesn't have PR but like
she's true she definitely does she has
PR and what's so funny is you know who I
think doesn't have PR Phil Maher yeah
Bill Maher just wrote out his feelings
and his thoughts and they were concise
and clear right but I feel like Bill
Maher gets a lot of backlash for stuff
like he knows what he works in politics
so it's like very I feel like every time
he releases an episode there's like
people for it and against it but he
never like retracts or whatever so he's
kind of been through this before I think
for people who haven't been through like
the backlash culture cycle it's
extremely jarring but you have to stand
your ground especially if you made your
decision with good reason right how are
you gonna let like people on Twitter
just decide for you for you and for your
team and your employees like if you're
going to work or if you're not gonna
work yeah the true thing is so weird to
me she just like walked into the fire
got burned walked down yeah like walk
out and leave yeah she also she was one
of a few shows that were deciding to
come back Jennifer Hudson was bringing
back her talk show the talk on CBS and
the whole um backlash fell on Drew which
isn't fair but she's the most famous her
show is probably the most and she was
the first to do it I'm not sure I'm not
sure
um but like not to be so rude like who
watches the talk okay
so
now all those other shows are following
you they're all pausing too no and I
feel like
someone has decided to ruin these like
these people's careers this is so one
characteristic of Drew no sense it's
it's such bad strategy it it appears as
if there's no strategy but I have to
imagine for a show this big a celebrity
this famous yeah there is some sort of
uh Team yeah it looks it looks seriously
like chaos like burning down for what
for nothing to not even end up doing
what you set out to do right right so
you're back in the same position but now
everybody hates you and you're back
where you started which was that there
was no show right
and I she never even ended up saying
what her reasoning was but I'm just I'm
sure the exactly Bill Maher people need
to get paid there's people outside of
the writers who are going broke in
solidarity with the strike and we're
gonna support the strike as much as we
can while also keeping lights on food
and food on the table for a number of
other people 100 like and I and and the
most important thing and people like
especially like online are so quick to
like use words and labels so she's being
called a scab crossing the picket line
and it's so important to remember her
bringing her show back Jennifer Hudson
bring your show back is not in violation
of the strike it's a sag approved thing
right so she's literally not breaking
any rules but she's still being labeled
and she's breaking like cultural rules
right in this culture like those labels
stick so hard she'll be known as a scab
for the rest of her life like who the
[__] wants that but you have to think
that she knew that that was going to
happen when she brought her show back
which was kind of admirable that she did
because she was like gonna do it because
it was like a crazy thing it was a crazy
thing but the
livelihoods of the people who work on
our show were more important than what
people online were going to call her but
I guess that's no longer true so in her
third statement since the Saga this is
what she wrote okay I have listened to
everyone and I'm making the decision
that's the problem you shouldn't have
listened to everyone listen to your girl
listen to yourself I am making the
decision to pause the show premiere
until the strike is over I have no words
to express my deepest apologies to
anyone I hurt
we really need to relax with language
you need to stab anyone no one got hurt
in the Drew Barrymore crisis of this
week and of course incredible team who
works on the show and has made it what
it is today she added that she really
tried to find a way forward with
production as the film and film film
industry enters its fourth month of
being on strike segaftra joined the
Writers Guild of America on the picket
line on July 14th
I truly hope for a resolution for the
entire industry very soon Drew concluded
so many statements so little things
being stated
I just didn't see like this year Drew
Barrymore like
acting a fool like so messy yeah this is
a crazy Trend yeah it to me it's the
same thing as Ashton and Mila like you
made a choice exactly you can't stand by
it and you just continue to debase
yourself no but you made a choice it
wasn't a light Choice I'm sure Drew
thought really hard she knew there would
be some pushback I'm sure she thought
really hard about bringing your shirt
back I'm sure Ashley Mila thought really
hard about whether or not they wanted to
write these letters they both made big
decisions really they were all grown
people right
weird something's in the water nobody's
working in Hollywood and they've all
gone mad mm-hmm
um I also want to say I've seen some
like you know crying online that like
Dancing with the Stars is a it's a wga
show like they do have writers for like
you know Tyra Banks yeah and so like
them returning is like I'm telling you
dancing with the stars is Never Gonna
air
they're next it's just a feel like I
have
are they getting backlash I guess the
thing is just starting upstairs is
there's not one person you can yell at
it's right it's not gonna fall on Drew
no it's not gonna fall on Julianne Hough
right it's not going to fall in Jamie
Lynn Spears yeah so the backlash will
kind of be leveled for everyone and I
think they could withstand it that's
what I think that's a that's a good
point
I'm so excited to get into our next
story but before we do I have to let you
know that today's episode is brought to
you by Branch Basics oh we're gonna be
here for an hour a brand I'm very
passionate about because their cleaning
supplies are non-toxic hypoallergenic
free of fragrance hormone disruptors and
harmful preservatives their baby and pet
safe and cost effective for all of those
reasons it's why I love Branch Basics
it's going to be a yes from Jax it's a
yes for me one having a Streisand you
need pet safe cleaning products but also
once you have kids like you really can't
be cleaning their things with the toxic
chemicals that we've been using for so
many years so I I gradually made the
shift over to Branch Basics first I just
used it for the kids and then I was like
why not me why why can't I be using
these lovely cleaning products as well
and it is so affordable and cost
effective their premium starter kit will
provide you with everything you need to
replace all of your toxic cleaning
products in your home it's really a
no-brainer they have a refill model so
once you run out the only thing you need
to repurchase is the concentrate and the
oxygen boost and the bottle of
concentrate is huge it will refill those
bottles of you know
streak free cleaner all-purpose cleaner
box cleaner Surface Cleaner over and
over and over again and so it is a great
bang for your buck you can say say 15
and get free shipping on your starter
kit when you use code toast at
branchbasics.com again that is code
toast for 15 off plus free shipping when
you purchase a starter kit and that will
have everything that you need to clean
your house from top to bottom while also
keeping all the members of your family
safe from toxic chemicals safe from
toxicity except for me oh I can't tell
you what turdy's gonna do I'm so toxic
Branch Basics couldn't even clean May
that's why they wanted me to read it so
true today's episode is also brought to
you by vegamore a brand that turdy and I
love very much I think more didn't want
me to read this one no look at my hair
and this wasn't a one that had to be a
Jackie
um but I am very passionate about it
that's her fall it's her fault so I am
always trying to do right by my body so
when it comes to my hair and scalp
Health finding a product that actually
works and is made with clean ingredients
honestly I didn't think that it existed
I thought I was gonna have to choose
yeah between my beloved toxic hair
products and the killing life the clean
life it always feels like a trade-off
but with vegamore you can get products
that are made with clean ingredients and
that give you visibly healthy hair and
scalp so with vegamore I'm able to have
visibly thicker fuller shinier longer
hair all without the harsh ingredients
and I do feel like my hair is in that
era right now yes your hair looks like
it's good you're reading this ad your
hair looks so healthy today thank you
and it's like that's my real actual hair
I use the vegamore grow line which
promotes scalp health and they have
everything from dry shampoo shampoo and
conditioner a scalp serum a nice scalp
scrubber you use that one massager thing
feels so good I use the shampoo and
conditioner every single day that I wash
my hair which is not every single day
and they are amazing they smell really
good but they also don't have those
toxic things that we do not like so give
your hair the power of the little pink
bottle with vagamore for a limited time
toast listeners get 20 off their first
order by going to vegamore.com toast and
using Code toast at checkout that's
v-a-g-a-m-o-u-e-g-a v e g a i know and
it's hard because I'm mispronouncing
everything but yeah but this is
important yeah
v-e-b-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast
slash code toast to save 20 on your
first order let me repeat that because I
messed it all up
toast code toast for twenty percent off
your first order thank you Jackie that
was painful all right ready for our
third story oh some very sad news um we
didn't talk about this on Friday did we
are having Amnesia Hugh Jackman and his
wife no okay divorce he's devastated not
wearing his ring 27 years now everyone's
like ever obviously everyone's like duh
he's gay me I'm like snitch get in there
oh yeah I heard snitch was spotted
outside his building yeah it was like
incredibly hot take like I don't think
Hugh Jackman is gay like he literally
Works in theater if he wanted to he
would like there's no shame in being gay
especially in the theater like it's the
most welcoming and he's in Hollywood
he's like every single room where being
gay and I know everyone's like well I
heard I don't think he's gay like if he
wanted to be gay he would be okay no
like why would he be closeted at this
point in his life he is 57 how old is he
hold on he's old yeah
he's 54 excuse me she's 67. I didn't
realize she was an older she was with an
older lady yes I knew that Deborah Lee
finesse it was like always a nice thing
about him that he had this like nice
Hamish looking wife at home and he's
like this you know Hollywood but
heartthrob not to get ahead of myself
I'm gonna add him to the list see if
there's anyone what about Sophia Vergara
obsessed obsessed
I just couldn't see her getting into the
theater do you know what I mean like
with if you are dating or married to
Hugh Jackman you have to support him he
was just you know on music man which was
like you have to go every night like
honestly it's a lot the theater is not
for the faint of heart no it's a lot of
like sitting around watching dancing
yeah maybe yeah sure the first couple of
weeks it's fun but for a life I I
couldn't do it I think Ben said I want
to join the theater I'd say call a
lawyer I'm out yeah what if he said I
want to join the theater but you don't
have to attend my performances oh that's
fine okay it's good to have hobbies yeah
yeah so this is sad because it's a
long-term marriage but it does open up
potential and I know that snitch
somewhere is very excited yeah Margaret
is in love with him and she doesn't have
like a history of like really liking gay
men
that Olivia Rodrigo song all the guys I
like her gay like Margaret doesn't have
that I'm telling you he's not gay
no I don't like I just don't think he
would be
gay and not come out like that just
doesn't make sense he's he's grown man
yeah
yeah I don't think he's gay and you know
a 27 year marriage is still a success
very sad to see it end but of course a
world of possibilities are now open for
him you added him to our list yeah yeah
it's kind of like a younger list and he
likes an older woman we're kind of like
our list it's kind of ageist yeah but
not anymore not anymore he's I mean
severely Ed Deborah Lee finesse too
she's 67 she'll really bring the uh but
she's like not famous no it's out there
we can't put her up there's no one on
this list for Hugh Jackman well let's
think about some um you know
older ladies so he's 57 so anyone I mean
he could go younger
what about Reese Witherspoon she's
married oh no she's divorced she should
be I'm listening to make like a separate
list like not to be Aegis but like
it's less interesting yeah
I don't see you with a fellow star I
don't either that's just because I
haven't yet now that I'm looking at
pictures of him like I'm thinking like
okay let's say he's gay I don't think
we'll ever live in a world where he
would come out I think he would like I
think he really loves Deborah Lee
and to be married for 27 years like
maybe he would find it like
disrespectful to her or like he wouldn't
want to like embarrass her I just I I
don't think he's gay but if he was I
don't think he would tell us at this
point right but how are you gonna like
live your life I know like that
I don't know I don't know if we'll ever
understand Hugh Jackman although there's
another article oh Hugh Jackman and wife
addressed rumors that he's gay before
years before splitting I just clicked on
this link from page six and the rumors
are just because he's in the theater not
because like anybody saw him sucking
dick like yeah so his sexuality has been
questioned throughout his career but he
and his now ex-wife Deborah were always
always ready to shut down these rumors
in 2013 he told Australia 60 Minutes
that he felt frustrated over the
constant speculation he said it's to me
not the most interesting thing about a
person anyway I do get frustrated for
Deb because I see Deb go ah this is just
crazy
and Debs chimed in and said if he was
gay fine he would say he's gay it's
annoying because it's not true in a
separate Interview With The Hollywood
Reporter that same year Hugh Jackman
shared that he that the rumors about him
being gay had started to take a toll on
his then wife he said just recently it
bugs her she goes it's big it's
everywhere he added noting that the
Australian actress would peruse the
internet often and spiral afterwards
however she later appeared to have a
better sense of humor about the chatter
surrounding Jackman's sexuality during a
q a
um in 2020 the mother of two reportedly
quipped of her then husband he's been
gay so many years I was gay too you know
when I did shame I was gay they were
shocked when I got married it's like
someone saying to Elton John he's
straight I'm sure he'd be pissed
that didn't really clear anything out no
and I think like this is going to be
obviously like one of the meaner things
that I've said but it's just like a fact
of life I think people look at them as a
couple and like assume you know he's
this Hollywood Starlet he's with like an
older lesser-known you know she's a
beautiful woman but people think they're
ill matched that's what I and I don't
feel that way I just want to say because
you're like smiling at me like just
because you said those shoes are not
yeah they're beautiful she meant to be
worn on a beautiful woman right
I did say it just like her like with the
same intonation and Rhythm you did but I
can't think of one reason why Hugh
Jackman would be gay and not come out
well
it's very possible you know we live in
amazing times where like you know
there's no you should be whoever you
want to be but I don't think you and I
could really like understand like
there's so much shame and like most I
would say you know gay young men they
conquer the shame in their late teens
early 20s and most people come out but
maybe he's still stuck at it and I don't
think he's gay it's like everybody knows
him better than he knows himself right
right no like I don't think he's gay
like I
I don't so I don't
so that's out on that
great
um speaking of
Saturday I don't know Katy Perry has
sold her catalog rights to litmus music
and guess how much she sold it for did
you see in the now guess how much her
like catalog of music is worth a lot
yeah 300 million good guess 225 I mean
in this Stark economy
so after months of rumors Katy Perry has
sold her music to litmus music the
carlisle-backed company co-founded by
former capital records President Dan
McCarroll for a whopping 225 million
dollars they announced a deal on Monday
it includes her stakes in her master
recording and Publishing rights for the
Five albums she released between 2008
and 2020 which are one of the boys
Teenage Dream prism witness and smile so
crazy like
Teenage Dream and prison like that's
where the value is yeah like yeah
witness one dollar smile zero
after years as a major Superstar during
the 2010s wow that's how they refer to
her now a major Superstar during the
2010s she has slowed her career focusing
on her residencies in Las Vegas her
philanthropy work and raising family
with her partner actor Orlando Bloom
um that's interesting because
how much did Justin Bieber sell his
music for because I always felt like his
was so low your iPad is so [__] loud
Justin Bieber
I feel like it was like 300 and I feel
like his should be way more music more
than Katy Perry you think like no
because Justin Bieber's like songs are
really big but it's him that's
so bad you know what I mean it's like
his fan that's true and the money had
been made from those songs already 200
million plus that makes sense to me to
me that felt low for him a lot of big
hits like the more contemporary like he
is like what do you mean even in his
like bad boy years he had like
two enormous Hits come out every year
yeah to me I remember when I saw this I
felt like it was low but to me 225 for
Katy Perry feels right but maybe it's
because she hasn't released like an
actual Banger that like changed the wave
of music
for 10 years actually the more I think
about it like these are two people who
are big Mega stars in the 2010s they
probably have the same number of albums
it tracks I actually completely disagree
I feel like Justin Bieber is so his
music is so current right but he sold
his old stuff but but that includes like
peaches like that includes things in the
last couple of years like yeah Katy
Perry has not released a song like that
anyone listened to in at least
seven years
I listened to when I'm gone I'm never
really okay like that was a collab with
kygo that's not like a big song I just
added to my like songs on Spotify so for
some reason whenever I think of like
Masters I think about the Justin Bieber
one because I feel like he did a bad
idea of Masters I hear a thing of Taylor
well of course but we don't know what
hers are worth because she never got to
buy them but I thought we knew how much
they were bought for in the 300 the 300s
well it's so crazy is that actually so
it sounds like everybody it if Taylor's
300 and Justin's 200 then it sounds like
you're saying that Katie got paid a lot
more than you think she's working but I
disagree I think no I think Katie
actually got a very good Fair Deal fair
I think Justin Bieber got a bad deal
do you think Taylor got a bad deal well
well not Taylor how much time do you
have right well no at the time think
about like who she was at the time that
was like lover time she was kind of like
a pop star in crisis like in the lover
time I think she like didn't really she
was getting older she didn't know how to
navigate being like a pop star bubble
gum pink like with being a mature older
woman and her songwriter like the lover
era was and I feel like we talked about
that a lot how like I'm now uncovering
like elements of the lover era that are
so amazing and I don't think I took it
seriously at the time because it was so
corny and it did feel inauthentic to her
at the time and that's why like Evermore
folklore and midnight did so well
because they felt so real to like who
she was so now I think the entire her
entire catalog of music has to be worth
half a million dollars
but at the time I think 300 was a good
price
I also don't know like what do they do
with this music when they buy it like
what is it they make money off of it but
like how much money and what things so
like I don't actually know
what you should pay for a song right
like I'm just comparing it to other
people what's that that crazy thing like
somebody owns Michael Jackson's music or
like Michael Jackson owns The Beatles
yeah or Elton Johnson like it's crazy
Michael Jackson owns The Beatles like
the rights to like a lot of their music
yeah that's so crazy and bizarre
yeah so random and speaking of Katy
Perry I was just watching an interview
with Miranda Kerr where she was just
talking about like how much she loves
Katy Perry and like I'm obsessed with
that whole dynamic yeah like Evan
Spiegel Miranda Kerr Orlando Bloom Katy
Perry like obsessed it's giving Blended
it's giving Blended
the blender beautiful Blended when I
think of like beautiful Blended I think
of like a thousand kids like they only
just have one kid and they really like
do everything they can for the kid it's
like so nice but Miranda and Evan have
you know I'm talking about the share of
child between its Orlando Bloom and
Miranda Kerr's baby right yeah yeah so
that's why they all have to co-parent
like vacations and she was talking about
like they plan all their trips they call
Katie like she like really likes Katie
because she genuinely does but because
she like made an effort to also it was
like really sweet that is really nice
and I just like I'm obsessed with
Miranda Kerr yeah like her life is
everything
okay we have one more story but before
we get into that story passion Queen
over here the passion never ends because
I have one more thing to say you should
say it Jax which is that today's episode
is brought to you by CeraVe CeraVe is
the number one dermatologist recommended
acne brand and has a line of products
developed specifically for acne prone
skin to promote a clear complexion all
formulated with three essential
ceramides you can disrupt the acne cycle
without disrupting the Skin Barrier
salicylic acid is a prime ingredient in
the center of the acne products and it
works to exfoliate and unclog pores
removing dirt and acne causing debris
cerave's acne control cleanser contains
two percent salicylic acid to reduce
blackheads and prevent new breakouts it
improves the appearance of pores and
contains oil absorbing technology making
it a great option for maintaining a
clear complexion and preventing new
breakouts they also have the CeraVe acne
foam cream cleanser which is 4.4 benzoyl
peroxide treatment which clears acne
pimples and helps prevent new breakouts
and allow skin to heal they launched a
new acne foaming cream wash and their
acne line is just so varied it has every
product that you will need they have
acne serum cream cleanser foaming wash
everything
facial moisturizing lotion for the am
and the PM which are great for morning
or evening routines the products are
available online and in store at CVS so
visit CVS in store or online at cbs.com
to receive buy one get one 40 off on the
entire CeraVe acne line the promotion
run September 17th to the 23rd so go
check it out at CVS CeraVe has all of
your facial needs okay I just want to
say like for the record tomorrow I want
to go back to regular like I don't like
reading the stories I feel like like it
just sucks like I hate it okay do you
hate it when you do it
no I'm used to it do you hate doing that
no so I like being in control of the
flow of the show
you think you have more control of the
flow of the show with ads yeah
I feel like I control the show the
stories kind of like Romeo and Michelle
okay our fifth and final Story main
character of the toast
I mean I don't think we should go there
like it's not good to pit women against
other women I feel like we go through
eras like you are recently coming out of
your main character like you like the
last couple months like what about you
you know oh really but you were like
doing I was more physically on camera
yes but like everyone was like talking
and worried about you and it's like I
you know and just like the lowly Street
rat you know yeah yeah no it's
interesting to think about Kim
Kardashian scolds her son saint for
giving the middle finger to Paparazzi he
is seven years old so Kim Kardashian was
in full mom mode when she scolded her
eldest son saint for using a brood hand
gesture the Skins founder looked Stern
when she noticed that the seven-year-old
holding his middle finger up to the
paparazzi after leaving his basketball
game on Friday in Los Angeles the mother
of four stepped out in a strapless top
in high-waisted jeans alongside her her
son
um why do we care what she's wearing the
youngster Saint was wearing his white
basketball jersey you just have to hit a
word count I know like he was wearing a
white basketball jersey when the trio
part of doing the stories where you have
to like you know read quickly and jump
okay so Saint giggled after after
flashing his middle finger which
resulted in a scolding from his mom who
briefly covered his face with her hand
these pictures are really funny
um and then later in the day she took
Northwest to dinner at nobum Alabama
it's like so weird no this is like such
a normal picture of like they're in some
parking lot like clearly going to
Chili's or something like they're in
their school uniforms he's with his
friend the friend's face is blurred
that's good but not I guess Saint is a
public figure like yeah they don't blur
it's just like such an oddly intimate
Affair like it looks like it could be
any family I mean not that the moms are
ever dressed like him but right it's
just security but it's so
um Regular yeah like why did the
paparazzi why are they at Chili's with
that right they're definitely going to
like like literally Applebee's
Neighborhood Grill for like after dinner
I mean after practice sliders yeah
oh speaking of Sliders
um
Jackie and I no we have lunch covered
today we ordered early like we're not
dumb we're so smart but Jackie and I
have been um
I signed up for Discovery plus and
Jackie and I have been just kind of I've
really been like feeling it's been
raining here a lot in the afternoons
it's so hot so we play outside and then
Honestly by three o'clock it's so
exhausting and it starts to rain so it's
like a perfect time to shower read watch
TV I love it I love what I hope it rains
today like I love it so yesterday we
were all laying in bed I'm like I think
we should watch like a cooking show so I
bought Discovery plus seven day free
trial so if I don't like it I'm Gonna
Cancel it like tomorrow but I've really
been enjoying it and I was really
wanting to watch like Aina or Pioneer
Woman or Giada like an OG like Food
Network girly and Jackie was like you
should watch Johnny Gaines and honestly
you didn't trust I had preconceived
notions you did so she put on every
other show first and it was just not
giving like the vibe especially the old
school shows like we look at them so
fondly but the way that we're used to
consuming content today they don't miss
so blurry and it's like but honestly I
really and I'm gonna be totally honest
like I didn't want to watch Joanna like
she's too thin like in my opinion not
too thin as like a person if you're
gonna be on like a cooking show like I
want like a big breasted like I want a
big woman Maybe
still like sweating over the like I want
a big woman to make my food to me that's
more believable and you know to be
making cookies like Giada DiLaurentis to
me she's inauthentic like so much pasta
so much cheese one pound like it's just
it doesn't feel real to me like I I
can't get I can't get lost I can't
escape because I'm doubting so much of
what's going on and I thought I would
experiencing I would experience that
with Joanna but what she really talks
about is she's this big old family yeah
she's really cooking for her kids yeah
and her recipes are like simple because
they're for children and I I doubted you
and once again I was wrong for doing
that not only does she cook things that
you would want to eat like you know not
getting crazy yeah but she uses like the
whole ingredients and the show Vibe is
very nice actually and it has all of
those things like I would I want to eat
what she makes we could barely find an
episode I don't want to like tarnish
another Chef right also those other
chefs have so many seasons that they've
already made sliders yeah now they have
to get into the crocom Boost we were
looking for Pioneer Woman Olivia loves
her she had 40 Seasons like where do I
start and we chose an episode that was
from her covered years yeah I didn't
realize like I just clicked on one she's
made 40 Seasons worth of desserts so
yeah we wound up watching a Blackberry
crepe cake which by the way looked
delicious but if I ever attempted to
make that cake it would take me 24 hours
yeah no she wasn't fooling anyone with
those Crepes right so just like wasn't
uh the thing about a cooking show is you
want it to be aspirational but you also
wanted to be like hey maybe we should
try that no it was so fun about the
Joanna one it's like we just kept
remarking on like her dishes and her
kitchen was so beautiful and then you
let me know that she actually did a TV
show building the Magnolia Studios for
her it was a two-part special that we're
gonna watch tonight behind the scenes of
how they set up her Studio kitchen she's
so like the thing is I invented Johnny
gates in this house and I will take that
to my grave I've never watched Flip or
Flop Fixer-Upper Flip or Flop don't get
me started on Flip Flip I've never
watched armed hike
that's flipper flop I know okay I've
never watched the gains you should I
don't like building shows I don't like
those shows okay so like I I don't even
I don't have anything against Joanna
like I love her brand I love her show
like I love her historically I just I
didn't trust her as a chef like she just
doesn't give me you know Chef bwe big
woman energy and I was wrong and that's
what I get for judging someone and for
doubting me because I told you it was
the exact content you were looking for
and it was like we searched we just
watched so many Bad episodes of like
Barefoot Contessa like we just couldn't
find like the vibe we were looking for
and Jackie was like chiming in in the
back of the bed like put on Joanna we
were like shut up Jackie and then we
eventually put on Joanna and she was
right it was everything it was yeah she
makes tasty looking food she has a
calming present she's gorgeous
kitchenware she cooks nicely yeah
swiftly not so you know complicated yeah
but like Aina makes like really
sophisticated dishes honestly like she's
making a chocolate truffle like I don't
want that we were looking for we were
like really hungry so we were looking
for like someone to make like a whole
episode of delicious dessert and Ina had
one called chocolate chocolate chocolate
or whatever and first thing she made was
I forget but it was fine and then she
starts making these Truffles and it's
like girl make a cake like Duncan Hines
like what's so good so complicated
Duncan Hines what'd you just say Duncan
Hans what's that excuse me
Duncan Hines what are you saying what
are you saying you don't know what
Duncan Hines is no it's a brand
maybe I'm saying it wrong no
d-u-n-c-a-n it's like the Box brand of
like brownies everything you buy oh I
don't know it I've never noticed it then
Duncan Hines yeah no look let me show
you like the Box you obvi wait are you
[__] with me like no that's like you
saying you don't know like Mrs Betty
Crocker
like all these boxes I've never noticed
let's go get one okay I would love to
make oh yeah I think we should bake I
think so too
we could make Joanna's Ranger cookies
also what I like about Joanna she has
cookbooks I've made a few of her recipes
and they are they were tasty they work
so Kim Kardashian's son give in the
middle finger to Paparazzi what I was
gonna say about that was now that I'm a
parent like I have stronger feelings
about certain things but I haven't
entered that era yet where like if Harry
was seven years and gave the middle
finger to someone who maybe deserved it
right I don't know how I would feel
about it yeah somebody who maybe
deserved it that's the question right if
he was giving the middle finger at
school his teacher stop I'm obsessed but
like I don't know I I imagine I would
like be like don't do that but I might
find it like secretly chuckle chuckle
chuckle I might chuckle so that's your
show Angel if you're watching this do
not do it Angel if you're watching this
come to your auntie I miss you so much
because yeah he calls me KOJA like Koji
cat coach a cat yeah that's how we spell
it c-o-j-a he's obsessed with me like
you guys I'm never leaving yeah great
thank you guys so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we'd
love for the past five stories dating
show everybody the Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video thumbs up for us available
videos
about a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are
uh bye
[Music]